- Today we will be talking about
how you can streamline AI
model development lifecycle,
as well as monitor
and do lifecycle management
for your AI workflows
using Amazon SageMaker AI.
My name is Khushboo Srivastava.
I'm a senior product manager at Amazon.
I manage the Amazon
SageMaker Studio product.
I have been with AWS for
almost six plus years.
Along with me are joining
Bruno, a senior specialist essay
and Manikandan, one of our
esteemed customers from KOHO
who will also talk
briefly about themselves.
- Hello everyone, thank you
for joining this session today.
My name is Bruno Pistone,
coming from Italy, Milan,
probably from the accent you can hear.
I'm a senior worldwide specialist
solutions architect in AWS
almost from five years and a half,
focusing on model training
and now model customization
for large language models.
Mani.
- Hi everyone.
My name is Manikandan Paramasivan.
I'm a senior staff architect
for data, ML and AI at KOHO.
I manage and lead the architecture infra
and operations for our
data and ML platforms.
Excited to be here to share our story
about how we SageMaker at KOHO.
- Perfect
- Awesome.
Innovations in generative
AI are quickly transforming
the business landscape.
IDC predicts global
spending on generative AI
is expected to reach $202 billion by 2028,
representing around 32%
of the overall AI spending
with a compound annual growth rate of 29%.
Citing significant
breakthroughs in generative AI,
Goldman Sachs predicts
that generative AI can increase global GDP
by as much as 7% or almost $7 trillion
and lift productivity growth
by 1.5 percentage basis points
over the next 10 years.
We are examining the growth
trajectory of generative AI.
As you can see from our slide,
we are witnessing unprecedented growth
and adoption rates across multiple fronts.
89% of enterprises are advancing
in generative AI
initiatives as of right now,
with 92% planning to
increase investments by 2027.
78% of organizations now use AI
in at least one of
their business functions
and 77% of organizations choose AI models
that are of size 13 billion
parameters or smaller,
which suggest a preference
for customization
and for customizable and
cost-effective models.
Achieving these benefits
is not without challenges.
Let's talk a little bit about challenges
that our enterprise customers face.
Our enterprise customers are
constantly sharing with us
couple of major challenges
in ML development.
First disparate
and disconnected ML tools
are significantly
increasing time to market,
teams are spending more
time managing tools
than developing solutions.
Second, isolation between team members
is a real killer in
productivity and collaboration.
Data scientists, AI developers
and business teams often work in silos,
leading to duplicated efforts
and missed opportunities.
Third, governing AI
and ML projects efficiently
becomes exponentially
more complex as you scale.
Without the right framework, security
and compliance can
become major bottlenecks.
And finally, availability
and management of infrastructure
is key to training
and fine-tuning machine learning
and large language models.
This slide talks a little
bit about the similarities
between a classic traditional
machine learning workflow
as well as a generative AI workflow.
We always start from preparation of data,
a GenAI project that means format the data
into the prompt template or
structure of the identified LLM.
Second, we select the
right foundational model
that we wanna fine tune for our use case
and with our own data.
Third, we run the workload on
the compute cluster required
and finally we evaluate
and deploy the model.
Amazon SageMaker Studio.
To address these challenges
and help our customers build
end-to-end ML workflows,
we launched Amazon SageMaker
Studio couple of years ago.
It provides a purpose-built,
end-to-end ML development platform
where data scientists can not only build,
deploy their models or
fine tune their models,
but also manage and
monitor their AI workflows.
Data scientists can select
an ID of their preference.
They can select from a choice
of our Studio, JupyterLab
or Code Editor built
on open-source VS Code.
They can use SageMaker Studio Notebooks
for data preparation.
They can write data
scripts for data generation
and preparation,
or they can use the
built-in EMR connections
to run their large-scale Spark workflows
for running their data
preparation jobs at scale.
Finally, they can select from
a hub of foundation models.
They can choose one of the pre-built
foundation model already available,
select a fine-tuning
technique of their choice,
any fine-tuning techniques
or reinforcement learning techniques,
or you can also bring in your own model
and train it from scratch.
Finally, deploy it in production.
SageMaker Studio provides
you a visual interface
for deploying your endpoints
in production as well.
And finally, you can manage
and monitor all your
endpoints, all your models,
everything under a single pane of glass.
The key thing to note
is that SageMaker Studio
provides multiple SageMaker
AI service offerings
within a single platform that you can use
for each step of your
AI development workflow.
You can also run experiments using MLflow
and you can monitor your experiments.
You can also build your pipelines
using SageMaker pipelines within Studio.
It could be as simple as drag
and drop to build a pipeline
or you could write your own code
in the SageMaker Studio Notebooks.
The flexibility is really your choice.
Today there are tens of
thousands of customers
using Amazon SageMaker AI, to name a few,
we have 3M, Coinbase, Intuit, Dominoes,
and many other that are
not listed on this slide.
Before we jump into the
details of each offering
involved in an end-to-end
generative AI project development
for building, fine-tuning
and deploying LLMs, we would
like to see in practice
how SageMaker AI can help developers
with these fundamental activities.
For this I will hand over the
mic to my colleague, Bruno.
- Thank you, Khushboo.
So in this demo we would
like to actually give you
a tangible example of what
are the main activities
that are related to a machine learning,
as well as a generative AI project.
And in particular,
we are going to start
from the data preparation
to fine tune a large language model
and then deploy this model
by using different type
of SageMaker AI or services.
In particular, I actually
prepared this architecture
by impersonating two main personas.
As a platform administrator,
I actually prepared
the environment for my development
and training and deployment,
and in particular I created a
private networking environment
as well as deploying the cluster
where I'm going to submit
these jobs by using HyperPod
with EKS orchestration as
well as using the same cluster
for the deployment.
For the development part,
I deployed SageMaker Studio
where basically I can give the possibility
to data scientist engineers
to connect, prepare data
and link Studio with HyperPod
by using a shared file system
with Amazon FSx for bplstone volume.
So as an engineer, data
scientist or developers,
I can connect to Studio,
I can select the IDE of choice,
that can be, for example,
JupyterLab or Code Editor.
I can start prototyping my code,
save the data in the shared FSx
in order to have this accessible
from the cluster itself.
And then once I'm ready I
can submit jobs for training
and deployment by using the HyperPod CLI
as well as the Kubernetes CLI kubectl.
Once the job is running,
I can monitor everything
in terms of what is happening
as well as training metrics
or system metrics directly
in SageMaker Studio
by using task governance capabilities
as well as manage them workflow.
Now we would like to actually
jump directly into the demo.
This is the SageMaker
Studio user interface.
I prepared the,
I can select the JupyterLab
space that I already prepared.
There are all the necessary
components installed.
I can connect to the JupyterLab space.
What is happening is that in
a few minutes it is loading.
So here I have my user interface.
I can click on or custom
file system, select the FSx.
I already prepared the entire content.
The first step is the data preparation,
but initially we want to actually install
all the necessary Python models
that I need for preparing the data.
So I can actually install
a requirements.txt
that contains all my Python models
and I can do interactively.
Once I'm ready, I can restart the kernel
and I can start the
data preparation piece.
I selected a model, Qwen3-4B
and I want to improve, as task,
the possibility to reason,
and or invoke tools that is
pretty important for Agentic AI.
Here I can define all the functions
for preparing this data
directly in the Notebook,
such as extracting the tool
content, the thinking content,
and validate the messages.
And after that I can
actually prepare the dataset
with a proper function.
What is going to happen is
that this function is
formatting the entire dataset
into the proper prompt
style accepted by the model.
We will see here with
all the specific tags
and highlighting what
are the main components
such as for example, system
prompt, how to invoke tools,
the reasoning and how
to generate the answer.
Once I'm ready I can
directly upload on Amazon S3
as well as save in the Share-ify system.
So here for example, I can
even access this data directly
from SageMaker Studio.
Now it's time to start
the training activity.
So the first thing is
to define the parameters
for my training workload.
So I specify where the
data are saved are stored
on the FSx for bplstone volume
and parameters such as
learning rate epochs.
Since I'm operating
with HyperPod with EKS,
I'm actually defining a manifest file
which contains all the information
around the PyTorch job,
such as the number of
distances, the GPU type
and docker image that they want to use.
Once I'm ready directly from JupyterLab,
I can open the terminal
and start interacting with HyperPod.
In this case, I used the
kubectl SDK I applied,
so I deployed the workload,
and here I can see that
there are two new pods
in my cluster.
I can investigate the
logs of the first one
and we will see that the first step for me
is actually to align the same environment
that is available on SageMaker Studio
with the pod environment
by installing the same
libraries to give continuity
to my workload.
I can clear the terminal,
and now I can actually investigate
what is the main node since
it is a distributed workload,
by analyzing what is the main address
that is acting in the cluster.
So it is the same pod,
and now I can actually
connect in order to see
what is happening in terms of workloads.
So here the model is actually downloading,
then the dataset is prepared,
and after a while it is actually
connecting also to MLflow
because we are going to track
all the these metrics directly
accessible from SageMaker Studio.
Once the job start we will see a new log
that is actually showing
the evolution of the epochs.
So now we want to actually
move directly in the Studio UX
and see directly in MLflow
what is going to happen.
So I already created an
MLflow tracking server.
I can open it.
(audience murmuring)
We will see that there
is a new experiment.
I can analyze directly in the graph
the metrics that I want to
collect for training metrics
as well as system metrics.
In this case, for example,
for the first node,
I'm also analyzing the GPU utilization
for this specific node, how it
is evolving during the time.
But if you want to
actually have more details
around is happening on
the cluster directly
in SageMaker Studio,
I can actually access
informations on the cluster,
on the HyperPod cluster,
and in particular,
under compute, HyperPod,
I can select the cluster
that is available.
I can see the task that are
ongoing such as for example,
here there is a new task that is running
and under metrics I can
actually see the evolution
of the utilization for
example for the GPU, CPU,
the total number of GPUs
available as well as the evolution
and utilization over the time.
Now I'm just waiting for
the completion of the job.
Once it finish I can see that the pod
are completed and the same
thing is actually available also
on SageMaker Studio in the console.
So the job, the task
is actually succeeded.
The model is actually
available directly in Studio.
So I can even use for offline evaluation,
which is actually pretty important
since there is this shared FSx.
Now I want to deploy the model.
So the first thing is to copy
this model into Amazon S3
in order to make sure
that this deployment is access,
this model is accessible
for the deployment component on HyperPod.
This is the manifest file
which is describing the deployment.
So it is saying where is the model located
as well as what is the instance
type that I want to use
and the container image,
also in this case that I
want to use a prebuilt one
that is the LMI container
offered by SageMaker.
In a similar manner,
what I can actually do is
to deploy this component
from SageMaker Studio.
So I clean the space
and I apply these new
deployment.yaml file.
This deployment is actually
creating different components
such as for example, the
inference endpoint configuration,
which is actually describing
what we saw in this manifest file,
but it is really important
because in case you have multiple endpoint
and you want to understand
what is happening,
this is actually the description of
what is the configuration
for the specific endpoint.
As we can see there are the
same kind of informations.
Now I can understand the
pods that are available.
So there is a new pod
that is under deployment,
I can describe it.
And what is happening is that
there are multiple images
that are created in order
to have, for example,
the web server up and running
in order to expose this endpoint,
I can go in Studio under
deployment endpoints,
I will see that there is this new endpoint
that is under creation.
I can refresh the page,
and once it is in service,
I can start interrogating my model.
So here I prepared a Notebook
that is directly using
the SageMaker Python SDK,
I defined the system prompt
in order to ask the model
to use the reasoning part
within this tag's think,
and just to repeat,
this was not actually a reasoning model,
this was an older version,
and once I'm invoking
and the prompt is, "Say
hello to re:Invent 2025,"
we'll see that the model is now improved
because it is actually now
following what I want to do.
There are the think tag
as well as we will see
the generated answer
that is actually reflecting
what is my specific task.
So as probably you understood
there are different phases
that are really, really
important for a machine learning
as well as for a generative AI project.
The first step is the
data preparation piece.
For the data preparation piece,
there are multiple ways in
order to prepare our data
for machine learning.
We saw in the previous demo
that we used an interactive
approach directly
in the JupyterLab Notebook.
So as a user I can connect
to the IDE of choice
in SageMaker Studio,
JupyterLab or Code Editor,
install whatever libraries I want
and start the preparation
piece with also the possibility
to select multiple instance
types in case for example,
I need more computational power,
but in case I have a lot of data
and I need to probably
distribute this workload
for data preparation,
I can actually connect JupyterLab
Notebooks to EMR servers,
EMR servers that can be self-managed,
so basically you manage the EMR server
as well as Amazon EMR serverless.
So the possibility to actually use
the serverless utilization of Amazon EMR,
and prepare this data
in a distributed manner
directly in the Notebook
by using Spark framework.
But if you want to actually operate
more in a programmatic approach
in an asynchronous manner,
so have this step into a proper pipeline
for machine learning
while also in this case
we can use a service of SageMaker AI
that is Amazon SageMaker
processing in order to create a job
that can use whatever framework
you want, so custom images
as well as prebuilt container
for example, for Spark,
and make this step as
part of your pipeline.
After the data preparation piece,
there is the training
of a machine learning
of a generative origin,
or a generative AI model,
and in particular when in
specifically for generative AI,
when we are talking with
leaders about, you know,
generative AI projects,
there are new challenges
and new questions that may come.
For example, which model should I use?
You probably ask your question
this question by yourself.
Every day, the open-source
world is releasing a new model,
so which is the right
one that I should use
and how I can access this type of model.
The question is how do
I customize my model?
Well, there are different
techniques that you may want
to apply that might be
related to your business goals
that you want to achieve.
And of course, how can I optimize
my training performances?
Now in the next slides,
we are trying to answer
all these questions.
From a technique approach,
there are different type of techniques
that we will want to apply
based on your business goals.
If I want to adapt a model
to a specific industry,
what does it mean, a specific industry?
For example, have the model
that knows specific terminology
of the industry you are
operating such as for example,
healthcare and life
science, financial services.
We are using continued
pre-training activity.
What does it mean in terms of data?
We are taking a text that can
be, for example a PowerPoint
or it can be a Word document.
We translate into a
machine readable format.
So for example, txt file
and we feed the entire
document into the model itself.
So the task for the model
is to predict the next token
that is basically the word
or the combination of the words
based on the entire context
that is passed to the model itself.
In case we want to teach
to the model a new task
or we want to improve the
capability of an existing task,
like for example, as I
did in the previous demo,
well in this case we are actually using
supervised fine-tuning techniques.
We supervised fine-tuning techniques,
we are actually using a dataset
that is named, labeled dataset.
Labeled dataset means that the,
like in this example we
have an array of messages
where there is an alternation
between user and assistant.
So the user is basically the user promise
that you want to feed,
so the user question,
and the assistant is the expected answer
that the model should generate.
So basically we are instructing the model
that given a user prompt,
the expected answer should be that one.
Then there are techniques
that are named post-training techniques
that are standing into the
preference alignment part,
preference alignment
part can be also related
to reinforcement learning.
It means that we want to align a model
in order to be more human-like
in the sense that it is
actually we want the model
that is generating answers
that are more similar
to what a human can generate, you know?
So basically what we are doing,
we are applying different type
of enforcement learning techniques.
That is just an example of
a dataset where basically
in that case we are providing
us input the user prompt
and we are giving to the model an example
of what is a good answer,
but we are also giving
to the model an example
of what is a bad answer.
So in this way, the model is actually,
we learn how to distinguish
between the two.
How to do it on SageMaker AI?
In the previous demo we actually used
a self-managed cluster with
Amazon SageMaker AI report.
With Amazon SageMaker HyperPod
we are talking about a
purpose-built resilient
and self orchestration infrastructure
for maximized resource control.
In this case, we have full
control of the cluster
that can be orchestrated with Amazon EKS
as well as for example with Slurm,
and we have also advanced
capabilities for task governance
and organizations in order
to organize, for example,
the execution of the tasks
based on the policies
that you want to define.
But in case you want to focus more
on the machine learning part,
so you don't want to actually
manage a proper cluster.
Well, in that case we can
use SageMaker Training Jobs.
That is a fully managed
resilient infrastructure
for large-scale and
cost-effective training.
In this case, with Training Jobs,
we actually prototype our code.
Once we want to submit the job,
we are actually invoking an API,
an API by specifying what
is the instance type,
the number of instances,
and SageMaker AI is
taking care of everything.
It's turning up the infrastructure,
executes the job.
Once the job is finished,
the infrastructure is turning down.
So you are paying, in
this on-demand approach,
only for the amount of time
that the job is under execution.
But of course if you have workloads
that are more predictable
so you know when to use
and how many instances to use,
there are options such as for example,
flexible training plan or spot instances
where you can reserve
some capacity upfront.
The observability part is
actually super important
that we saw in the previous demo
and in this case in SageMaker AI
and in particular in SageMaker Studio
we have actually a lot of
options in order to do that.
For example, we saw that
with SageMaker HyperPod,
we can use task governance
capabilities within Studio
in order to analyze what are the tasks
that are under execution.
We can also define custom policies
in order to prioritize specific customers,
for example, specific task pair, I dunno,
based on the team as well
as based on the priority
that we want to give to the workload,
in a similar manner we can
actually do the same thing
with Training Jobs.
We can actually analyze the
metrics that are related
to the cluster that is used
for the training job itself
and orchestrate the execution
of these jobs by using,
for example, the connection
between Training Jobs
and AWS Batch.
Regarding which model should I use?
Well last year during the re:Invent 2024,
we released this capability
that is named Amazon
SageMaker HyperPod recipes,
which is a curated,
ready-to-use set of parameters,
so set of recipes for open-source models
such as for example, DeepSeek,
Meta, Llama, Mistral,
as well as first-party model
since starting from the New
York Summit of this year,
we have also the possibility
to customize Amazon Nova models
with SageMaker AI.
But what is a recipe?
It's a collection of parameters
that are pre-configured and
related to the model itself.
So we basically have to just
the recipe that we want to use
without actually writing any kind of code
and SageMaker AI takes
care of the execution
of the workload itself.
The recipe is available for
both SageMaker Training Jobs
as well as for SageMaker HyperPod.
In the training job part,
we can use the SageMaker Python SDK
just to specify what is the
recipe that we want to use
and in a similar manner with HyperPod,
we can use the HyperPod CLI
in order to submit those jobs.
Regarding the deployment
part, also in this case,
we have actually two options
in order to deploy those models.
The first one is to use
SageMaker Managed Inference.
So if we want to stay in the
area of fully managed approach,
what is SageMaker Managed Inference?
It is offering the possibility
to use fully managed real-time endpoints
with automatic scaling.
So what does it mean?
We can actually define
auto scaling policies
in order to scale up
and scale down based
on the spikes that can,
you can receive during the day
based on the request of the model itself.
But if we want to maximize
utilization of the cluster
that we used also for
the training workload,
while also in that case we can reuse
the same HyperPod cluster
as we did in the demo
and deploy those models in
the same HyperPod cluster.
And in particular, in order
to accelerate the deployment
of open models since New
York Summit of this year,
there is also the possibility
to actually deploy directly
from SageMaker Studio
in literally few clicks,
open-source models directly
from the Studio interface
by selecting the HyperPod
cluster that might be up
and running within your account.
Now I am calling back Khushboo
in order to discuss about the
recent launches that we did.
- Thank you, Bruno.
Alright, so let's talk about some
of the recent launches in
Amazon SageMaker Studio.
Before we start, I just
wanted to reiterate
that Amazon SageMaker Studio
provides you a suite of IDEs.
AI developers can pick
an IDE of their choice.
These are all fully managed IDEs
and the three key IDEs that
we provide are JupyterLab,
it's a web-based IDE for
Notebooks, code and data.
Its flexible
and extensible interface allows you
to easily configure ML workflows.
- [Speaker] I think
you have a lot of time.
- Code Editor based on
open-source code OSS,
boost productivity with
its familiar shortcuts,
terminal debugger and refactoring tools.
And RStudio,
RStudio is a fully managed
IDE for R with a console,
a syntax highlighting editor
that supports direct code execution
and tools for plotting, history, debugging
and workspace management.
Remote access from local IDE.
For AI developers who prefer to operate
and develop code in their local IDE,
such as the local Visual Studio Code IDE,
but at the same time wanna benefit
from the compute infrastructure
defined for cloud IDE
on SageMaker Studio,
we recently released the capability
where you can connect your local IDE
from your SageMaker Studio Spaces,
with remote connection to IDE,
we leverage SageMaker AI's
powerful compute resources
and your data to analyze
process data, develop AI models,
while maintaining all the
existing SageMaker Studio
security controls
and permissions without any additional
configurations required.
With AWS toolkit integration,
your Visual Studio Code IDE
can show all your SageMaker
Studio Spaces in the left nav.
As you see in the GIF here,
all you need to do is
enable remote access,
open it in Visual Studio,
and there you go, you have
your spaces right there.
Trusted identity propagation.
Trusted identity propagation is a feature
of AWS identity center where you can send
the end user's identity,
which is the human user identity
across all the workflows
within Amazon AWS services.
So let's say a user logs in
using AWS Identity Center
into their Amazon SageMaker Studio
and open SageMaker Studio
Notebooks to connect
to downstream AWS services
such as Redshift, EMR,
Lake Formation,
or ML services such as SageMaker training,
SageMaker processing
or SageMaker Inference.
Their human user identity
or the corporate identity defined
in IDC will get propagated
through all these workflows
and they will get logged
into CloudTrail logs.
So as an admin you can now go ahead
and audit who accessed which resources.
Not only that,
if you want to apply fine
grain access controls
using S3 access grants Lake
Formation access grants,
or Redshift data APIs, you can do so.
You can say that Khushboo
as a user should have access
to these S3 buckets only
and SageMaker Studio will honor that
thanks to the TIP integration.
Amazon Nova customization
on SageMaker Studio.
Early this year we released the capability
where users can customize
Amazon Nova models
on SageMaker AI.
Everything from SageMaker Studio.
Users can explore multiple
Amazon Nova models
such as Nova Micro, Light and Pro.
They can select their preferred
customization techniques
for their use case such
as supervised fine-tuning
or reinforcement learning techniques.
They can open a pre-built Notebook
to start customizing their workloads
on SageMaker Training Jobs
or SageMaker HyperPod.
As you see, this is an example
where you can open a sample Notebook
and it drops you into a Notebook
where you can do the customization.
IDEs and Notebooks on SageMaker HyperPod.
You can now maximize your CPU
and GPU investments across
each stage of ML lifecycle
by running IDEs and Notebooks
also on Amazon SageMaker
HyperPod clusters.
Last week we launched a new capability
which lets you install a new add-on
on your HyperPod EKS clusters.
The name of the add-on is
Amazon SageMaker Spaces.
What is this add-on? What is a space?
A space can be thought of
as a self-contained entity
where you can define all the
configurations such as image,
computer sources, local
storage, any persistent volumes,
and even more configurations
that are required
by AI developers to run their IDEs.
For AI developers,
this means accelerating
gen AI development.
Now AI developers can
launch their JupyterLab
as well as Code Editor
IDEs on web browsers
or connect their local IDE
such as local VS Code IDE
to run Notebooks on the
HyperPod compute cluster,
which means they can now run their IDEs
on the same persistent clusters
where they have their training
and inference workloads
using their familiar tools
such as HyperPod CLI
or sharing data across
interactive AI workloads
and Training Jobs using the
already-mounted file system
such as FSx or EFS,
it provides faster ID startup latencies
with image caching and
supports idle shutdown.
Not only this,
AI developers can now
maximize cluster utilization.
We support MIG profiles for GPU sharing.
So now AI developers can
bin pack multiple spaces
onto a single instance.
But not only that,
they can also bin pack
their multiple spaces
on a single GPU.
Thus they can run IDEs on
fractional GPU as well.
For the admin persona,
this means unified
governance and observability.
Administrators can now leverage
SageMaker HyperPod's task governance
to efficiently utilize GPU investments
across diverse workloads
and they can view memory, CPU,
and GPU usage across diverse workloads
and reprioritize using SageMaker
HyperPod task awareness
as well as HyperPod observability.
Now we are going to see a brief demo
for the capability for Amazon
SageMaker Spaces add-on.
But before we get into the demo,
I wanted to quickly call out a few things
that we would be seeing today.
First we will see how can you go ahead
and install Amazon SageMaker Spaces add-on
on an existing HyperPod cluster.
You can also install it
on a new HyperPod cluster.
There are two ways to install it.
Quick install comes
with automatic defaults
and custom install is
where you can provide
your own custom install also
comes with automatic defaults
but you can override those defaults
with your own configurations.
We discussed what a space already is,
it's a self-contained entity
where you can define different specs
and configurations that will be used
to run your IDE on HyperPod.
I also wanna briefly talk about templates.
Templates are a mechanism
that you as an admin can use
to create default templates
for defining some default configurations
for your Amazon SageMaker Spaces.
So let's say if you want teams to use
a specific set of custom images
or if you want your teams to
bring in their own images.
If you wanna define
already-mounted file systems,
local storage, you wanna define the range
of the local storage minimum to maximum,
you wanna define compute resources,
default resources required to run a space.
Everything could be done using templates.
We provide you two default
templates, one for JupyterLab
and one for Code Editor.
But you can go ahead
create your own template
and then mark it as a default.
And the last thing I wanted to call out is
that your AI developers
can access their spaces
in a visual interface as well.
How can they do it? There are
three ways they can do it.
One is using web browser.
In this web browser, the
admins provide a custom DNS
and all that the AI developers have to do
is run a HyperPod CLI command
to generate a web UI URL.
If they click on it opens their
JupyterLab plain vanilla IDE
on their web browsers on the custom DNS
provided by the admins.
Second way to access their spaces is
through their local IDE VS Code.
Again, as an admin you
can choose to define
that you want to enable remote connection.
If you do, then all that
your AI developers have
to do is run a HyperPod CLI command
to get the URL or a string
that you can then click
and it directly prompts you
to open your VS Code IDE
and opens your space
directly in the VS Code IDE.
Let's say if you,
if your AI developers
don't wanna use web browser
using custom DNS or remote
connection to their local IDE,
they can still access their spaces
using Kubernetes local
port forwarding feature,
which will open up your
plain JupyterLab IDE
on your web browser.
So let's get into the demo.
So we click on the custom install.
Here you see options to create
remote access configuration,
which is connecting to local IDE
as well as web browser
access configuration
where you provide a custom
DNS and a valid certificate.
You provide your KMS key and hit install.
Awesome, so your add-on is now installed
on the ML training cluster.
Now you can see two default templates
that we provide by default,
we will now create a default,
another template for your end users.
You can the application type,
if you have task awareness
enabled for this cluster,
you can select a preexisting
task awareness priority label
to assign to all these spaces
created using this template.
Here is where you provide your images.
Please remember that you can use
SageMaker distribution images, SMD images,
as well as provide ECR repos.
Your data scientists can
bring in their own images.
This is where we define the storage.
The storage is we have built
storage using local EBS.
You define your compute, GPU, CPU,
as well as memory per space.
And finally you define a
lifecycle configuration script
that you want to use to run your spaces
so you can install any custom
package that you need to,
and you have your template ready.
Now you can go ahead
and make this new template
as your default template.
Now let's see how you can
set up namespace as well.
Here what we will see is how
to create a new namespace
or use an existing namespace,
for existing namespaces
we will also show you task
governance namespaces.
You can then go ahead
and create EKS pod identity associations,
which are the service accounts
with which your space will run these.
Once you create the service accounts,
you can assign a runtime
role to these as well.
(audience softly murmuring)
Now that you have defined
some service accounts
and their runtime rules, you
can go ahead and create users.
You can create users and groups.
When you do so, you can assign them
one or more service accounts,
which means when a user is running a space
in a given name space,
they will be able to use from
a set of service accounts
to run their pods or
spaces in this scenario.
Awesome!
You can also see a list of spaces
that the users are running
on the HyperPod cluster.
As an admin you have the
controls to manage these spaces.
Let's say you wanna stop
a space, restart a space,
or if the user leaves the company
and you want to delete a space
from consuming any further resources,
you can take those actions
directly from the console.
Now we will go ahead
and see how the data scientist persona
will create spaces.
What we see here is the
data scientist persona
running the help command
and finally creating a space
with the name data science space
and using default configurations.
If you list, you see the space is running
and is the status available is true.
If you describe these space,
you can see all the configurations
or specs of the space.
Key thing to note is that
data scientists can use
the default configurations,
but they can also override or
customize these spaces back.
If you stop the space
and list the space, you will finally see
that the status has changed
from available to false.
All right, let's start the space again,
and we see these status changing to true.
As we said, talked about,
data scientists can update the space too.
In this scenario, we are
updating the memory computer
sources as well as the display name.
So once the update is done
and you run a describe command,
you'll see that these spec
of the space have been updated.
You can get logs for your space as well
if you want to deep dive
into a specific scenario
or troubleshoot.
Finally, you can access this space
as we talked about using a web UI URL.
If you click on this URL, it
directly opens up your space
as a open, as a plain vanilla IDE
on your local web browser.
You can run delete command as well.
And then if you describe,
sorry, if you list it,
you will see that the space doesn't exist.
Alright, with this we conclude the demo.
One thing that we haven't
covered here in the demo is
how you can generate the web UI URL
or the VS Code connection
URL that can directly open.
So if you click on those URLs,
it'll prompt you to open your VS Code IDE
or open up your IDE space
in the local web browser.
Awesome!
With that we will talk
about how SageMaker AI
has helped KOHO accelerate
their ML journey.
And I'll give the mic
to Mani then, thank you.
(audience softly chattering)
- Hi everyone, can you hear me okay? Cool.
Thank you, Khushboo, and thank you, Bruno.
Quick intro about me, Manikandan,
I'm a senior staff architect at KOHO.
I lead the architecture, infra engineering
and operations for our data
and ML platform, all that.
Plus I'm also a busy dad
to a 6-year-old daughter.
I'm excited to share how we
use SageMaker Studio in KOHO.
First a quick context about KOHO.
KOHO is a Canadian FinTech
founded in 2014 with the mission
to provide better financial
solutions for all Canadians.
Today we have over 2 million
customers using our products
across banking, credit and lifestyle.
We have products ranging from checking
and savings account, line of credit,
buy now pay later, insurance,
we even have eSIM for
international travelers.
We are about 230 employees in total.
That's a startup size
team who we are facing
and growing at enterprise scale
and facing and building
enterprise scale solutions.
So that's exactly where SageMaker Studio
became critical for us, that
friction of startup resources
with enterprise demands.
We start with the challenges
we faced, first, vendor cost.
Like many startups, we
started with different vendors
for different machine learning use cases.
We used to spend about $1.5 million
just for our real-time fraud
deduction use case alone
because typically the
vendors-based solutions
charge based on the API
based as as we grow,
as our customer base increase,
as our transactions volume
increase, our cost exploded.
Next, performance requirements.
In real-time use cases
like fraud detection,
we cannot compromise on speed.
We need to make the fraud decision
and return the response
within 50 milliseconds
as our customers are
waiting at the checkout
using their card.
Next, security and data access.
We are a regulated financial institution.
We wanted to make sure our
customer's data is safe.
We wanted to make sure the
data stays within our VPC.
At the same time we wanted
to give secured access
to all these data in our warehouse
and lake to all of our data scientists
for experimenting and building models.
And finally we needed a
end-to-end ML platform.
We are a lean data scientist
who cannot afford our time
stitching together different
tools to do our job.
So we needed a single IDE to access data,
to engineer features, to train models,
and deploy and operate in production.
So those are the problems
and those are the situations we were in.
I'll be show you how
we use SageMaker Studio
in our development environment.
So with that vendor cost
as a primary problem,
we started our in-house
model development journey
back in 2023 with SageMaker
Studio as a core foundation.
Today we have over 20 data scientists
and ML engineers using our domains
across four different teams, fraud risk,
credit risk, marketing,
and our own platform team.
JupyterLab is the primary IDE
most of our engineers use,
some prefer Code Editor as
well, Studio gives both.
So when our data scientists login
to our internal SSO portal,
they get redirected to the
team-specific Studio domain
in which their own individual
JupyterLab environment
is provisioned and
everything is ready for them,
everything is already connected.
They get to access the data in the lake
and warehouse securely and
they get to access glue and EMR
and SageMaker processing jobs
for data processing and model development.
And every team have a dedicated S3 buckets
for storing intermediate data,
and access for all this
is managed through IAM.
From a platform perspective, we manage,
provision and manage all
these through infrastructure
as code terraform.
So when we want to onboard
a new data scientist,
all we had to do is just a single PR
to create a user profile
and they're ready to go.
So that's how we set up our
development environment.
Now let me show you how we
deploy models in production.
This is our complete end-to-end
ML platform architecture.
I know there is a lot here,
but I just wanted to show
how this all connects end to end.
So it all starts with the SageMaker Studio
as a model development environment.
This is where our data scientist
explore the data engineer features,
experiment with different models,
and finally, when they're ready
to move this to production,
we use AWS-managed Airflow
as our MLOps pipelines
orchestration engine.
So these pipelines trigger
the SageMaker processing job
for feature engineering at scale
and they trigger Training
Jobs for model training
and everything gets versioned
and registered in the model registry.
It's the same pipelines that
we build for model evaluation,
model monitoring, our scoring pipelines,
our rollout pipelines
for different models.
When we want to deploy these
models for real-time serving,
we use SageMaker endpoints.
That's a key component in
meeting our latency requirement
of 50 milliseconds,
and the entire ML platform is built on top
of our core data platform, which
is S3 for raw data storage,
Redshift for warehousing.
And we use SageMaker
Feature Store for storing
and serving ML features
both in real, off, online
and offline board.
So SageMaker Studio is
not only giving us the IDE
for model development,
but it's also giving us a visibility
of everything you see
here in this diagram.
So from the same IDE,
our engineers can explore
all the existing features
in the Feature Store.
They can look at all the Training Jobs
and the history, their
experiments, results,
all the models that are registered
and all the endpoints that are deployed,
all that from one single IDE,
so they don't have to
jump different consoles
to gain visibility into
their ML lifecycle.
And everything is deployed within our VPC
and the data never leaves our boundary.
So that's our complete architecture
from how we build model,
how we deploy in prod, how
we monitor and we operate.
Now let's talk business.
Cost, that's our primary problem.
We went from spending $1.5
million per year with our vendor
to just $26,000 per year with SageMaker.
That's a 98% age cost reduction.
That's right, 98,
with over $1.47 million in annual savings.
That's huge for a startup and
any company for that matter.
And we are processing over 1
million transactions per day
with just 15 milliseconds average latency,
way below our budget of 50 milliseconds.
Because we built the models
on top of our own data
from our data platform, from
our own custom ML platform,
we get to improve the model's accuracy,
reduce false positive in our
fraud detection use case.
That means less dispute
claims, more happy customers.
Would you stop in the real-time
fraud deduction use case.
We scaled the same solution
across many different use cases.
We are building models for
underwriting our loan products
for predicting the user churn
and marketing use cases like LTV and more.
And now we are moving to GenAI
and LLM-based applications
and solutions as well.
The way SageMaker Studio helps us is
the same Studio environment
our data scientists
and ML engineers gets to
access to the foundation models
through Jumpstart.
So that's where we access
these foundation models
for prototyping, test our prompts,
compare our prompt results,
compare different models,
model distillation,
fine tune as needed for
that particular prototype.
Once those prototyping is complete
and we prove the value,
though we take those solutions
and deploy them in purpose-build tools
and infra like EKS for example
or Bedrock directly APA
calls to Bedrock in some cases,
so with that SageMaker
Studio first approach,
we have many use cases
in production today.
Our compliance team
is generating anti-money
laundering reports faster.
We have an enhanced
merchant categorization
that drives our accuracy
of our customer's cashback percentage.
We are analyzing our
customer's feedback faster.
We are prioritizing our product requests
and roadmap based on those insights.
The key takeaway is SageMaker
Studio is a single IDE
that can help with both
building, deploying
and operating traditional
machine learning models
and also experimenting, prototyping,
and building GenAI and LLM applications.
To conclude, SageMaker
Studio gave KOHO the power
to build enterprise scale
and cost-effective solutions
with our startup agility.
Thank you everyone.
I hope you find this
useful in your ML journey.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, Mani.
Before we conclude the session,
we would like to share some material
related to the official
Amazon SageMaker AI website,
as well as customer quotes
and references on how SageMaker AI helped
across multiple type of use cases,
as well as some links related to workshops
that you can start with for understanding
how SageMaker AI works
and test all the different capabilities.
Before we complete the session
I kindly ask you to rate
the session on the app,
this is really, really important for us
to improve the content
of the future session.
And I would like to thank you
again for attending this one
and hope you can enjoy the rest of the day
and the rest re:Invent.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)